foreign
[Music]
books today is the day we finally get to
show you what amd's new flagship rdna3
GPU has to offer the long anticipated
Radeon RX 7900 XTX this has to be one of
the most hyped product releases of the
year which could be a bad thing as
products rarely live up to the hype so I
guess we'll see a month ago AMD touted
50 to 70 performance gains for the 79
XTX over the 6950 XT and then it plays
it within Striking Distance of the much
more expensive RTX 4090 for
rasterization performance and we saw
many online commentators create mock-up
graphs showing exactly that so the
internet went into a Fizz salivating the
promise of RTX 4090 light performance
for a thousand dollars US and sure we
all knew it would only be for
rasterization performance but that's
what most of you really care about
anyway so it was still very exciting Tim
though was quick to note that if AMD was
really offering performance that was
close to the RTX 4090 that the price
would be much higher as amd's not your
friend leaving him to conclude that Ray
tracing performance must be really weak
or AMD were overselling the 7900 xdx's
capabilities of course today we finally
get to find out but before we do
today's sponsor spot is brought to you
by hetzna hetzner is a leading hosting
provider and data center operator in
Europe with hundreds of thousands of
servers in operation by combining its
strengths in Innovative technology
attractive prices expert support and
flexible customer service hetzner
expanded its Market both within and
outside Europe they operate their very
own high-tech data centers in Germany
and Finland hetzner also offers high
performance Cloud servers for an amazing
price and not only this hetzna is now
already covering both the east and west
coast of the United States with their
latest location in Hillsborough Oregon
now you can deploy cloud service in five
different locations and benefit from
features like load balances block
storage and more so for more information
please check the link in the video
description
okay so I'm not going to dive into all
of the specs I assume that most of you
have already watched our rdna3 news
video which covered all that information
and if you didn't feel free to check it
out but look in summary the 7900 XTX is
coming in at an MSRP of a thousand
dollars US while the very similarly
named 7900 XT that'll cost nine hundred
dollars the XTX version packs
6144 cores while the XT model has been
cut down by 13 to
5376 cores boost clocks for the XTX are
rated at 2.5 gigahertz while the XT has
been dropped by four percent to 2.4
gigahertz and then we see that the
infinity cache has been dropped from 96
megabytes to 80 megabytes so there's a
17 reduction there dropping the
bandwidth from three and a half
gigabytes per second to 2.9 gigabytes
per second now both models do utilize 20
gigabits per second gddr6 memory but
while the XTX receives a 384-bit wide
memory bus for a bandwidth of 960
gigabytes per second the XT has been cut
down to a 320 bit wide memory bus
resulting in 800 gigabytes per second so
another 17 reduction there so just a 10
discount the 700 XT doesn't appear as
though it's going to be particularly
Great Value based on the paper spec and
we'll look at that part in tomorrow's
video for now we want to focus on the
XTX version other noteworthy features of
the 700 XTX is the 355 watt total board
power rating Which is higher than that
of the RTX 4080 but like the 4080 it
does utilize the pcie 4.0 times 16
interface
of course the most interesting aspect of
these new rdna3 gpus is its use of
chiplet Technology rather than going all
out with a massive monolithic die rdna3
uses a combination of smaller dies in a
similar strategy to that of amd's latest
ryzen CPUs this means that to get those
top end GPU configurations AMD no longer
needs to make a single 520 millimeter
square dial grader like they did with
our DNA 2 or approach the Behemoth that
is ad-102 a 600 millimeter square die
that is used by the RTX 4090 amd's rdna3
chiplet approach includes two components
the graphics triplet dial gcd which
houses the main wgps and processing
Hardware plus multiple memory chiplet
dies or mcds which include the infinity
cache and memory controllers
on the flagship Savion XTX we get one
gcd plus six mcds while the 7900 XT
features a cut down gcd plus five mcds
amd's architecture benefits in multiple
ways from this move to chipler
technology one is that they can now
split their GPU design over multiple
nodes reducing the amount of expensive
Leading Edge silicon they need for every
single product the gcd is built on
tsmc's latest 5n node but the mcds are
built on tsmc n6 which is a derivative
of their older and less costly seven
nanometer process this ends amd's
Reliance on needing huge chunks of the
latest silicon for every high-end GPU
the other main advantage is yields put
simply large monolithic dies have lower
yields than smaller dies so whenever a
design can be split into multiple
smaller Dives there's a good chance the
yields will increase substantially AMD
has found great success using this
approach on their ryzen CPUs where
modern's N4 chiplets are about 70
millimeters squared so tiny enough that
yields would be well over 90 percent
rdna3 won't have as much of an advantage
as N4 as the gcd is still relatively
large compared to a CPU but at 300
millimeters Square it's still half that
of ad102 and just 60 as large as an rv21
so that sort of size saving will have
big implications for yields flanking the
gcd are six mcds about 37 millimeters
squared in size so these are tiny
chiplets and are just half the size of a
Zen 3 CPU core triplet each has a 64-bit
gddr6 controller and 16 megabytes of
cache and on a miniature node like n6
these should have extremely high yields
so AMD will benefit a lot here even
though they need six of them for the
7100 XTX pull up while Flagship Navi 31
arduino3 GPU still need over 500 square
millimeters of silicon this chiplet
approach split across two nodes should
reduce manufacturing costs and increase
yields so it'll be very interesting to
see how this approach plays out and
we're here to do just that
now for testing all gpus have been
tested at the official clock
specification so no Factor overclocking
and the CPU used is the ryzen 7 5800x3d
with 32 gigabytes of dual rank dual
Channel ddr4 3200cl14 memory on the MSI
MPG x570s carbon Max Wi-Fi in total I've
tested 16 games at 1440p and 4K so let's
get into the data
first up we have Watchdogs Legion and
here the 7900 XT looks Mighty impressive
cranking out 172 FPS at 1440p to make it
faster than not just the RTX 4090 but
also the RTX 4080 beating the ladder by
a 12 margin of course the RTX 4090 is
CPU bound here but it's interesting to
see that under CPU bound conditions the
Radeon GPU does have a bit more Headroom
now the CPU bottleneck is removed at the
4K resolution but even so the 700 XTX
was still nine percent faster than the
RTX 4080 then when compared to amd's
previous generation Flagship part the
6950 XT we see a 36 performance uplift
for the new 7900 XTX
the kalistoi protocol is a new game that
we've added to our benchmarks and it's
one where the 7900 XTX appears to work
quite well and please note I'm not using
the built-in Benchmark for this testing
with 166 FPS on average the new Radeon
GPU was eight percent faster than the
RTX 4080 and 50 fast and the 6950 XT so
that's a solid gain at 1440p
then at 4K with the ultra quality preset
which does use fsr2 the 700 XTX and
rtx48 it went neck and neck making the
rdna 3 GPU 44 faster than the 6950 XT
now I think amd's dealing with a
driver-related issue for rdna 3 and
Forza Horizon 5 because performance
wasn't that good here I should clarify
that there was no kind of stability
issues or bugs seen when testing but
performance was much lower than what
you'd expect to see at 1440p for example
the 700 XTX was just six percent faster
than the 6950 XT so that kind of sucks
the margin did improve a lot at 4K but
even so here the 700 XTX was just 16
faster than the 6950 XT and this is a
far cry from the sort of 50 typical
result that AMD was suggesting in their
announcement this meant that the new
Radeon GPU was five percent slower than
the RTX 4080 so a disappointing result
all round
here we see that amd's new Rd and A3 GPU
trailed the RTX 4080 at 1440p and
Rainbow Six extraction by a slim margin
making it just 26 faster than the 3090
TI and 36 faster than the 6950 XT again
although those are some decent margins
it's a lot less than what AMD initially
suggested or indicated
then at 4K the 700 XTX falls behind the
RTX 4080 by nine percent margin and is
now a mere 15 faster than the 3090 TI
though it was at least 47 faster than
the 6950 XT
Far Cry 6 is largely GPU bound at 1440p
so the 700 XTX is able to roughly match
the RTX 4090 despite being just seven
percent faster than the 6950 XT moving
to 4K though does alleviate the CPU
bottleneck and now the 700 XTX is 17
faster than the RTX 4080 and 25 faster
than the 6950 XT and although that is a
reasonable margin I expect that most
will be disappointed with what we're
seeing here relative to the 6950 XT
despite it being quite an impressive
margin over the RTX 4080. the new Rd and
A3 GPU looks quite good in Assassin's
Creed Valhalla outpacing the RTX 4080 by
an 11 margin at 1440p though this is a
title where Radeon gpus traditionally do
very well and if we turn our attention
to the 6950 XT comparison the result is
a lot less exciting as here the 7900 XTX
is just 24 faster interestingly at the
4K resolution the 700 XTX performs
better relative to the GeForce gpus than
what we saw at 1440p as here it matched
the RTX 1490 making it 16 faster than
the 4080 and this time 33 faster than
the 6950 XT which is a decent margin but
also a lot less than the 50 to 70
percent margin AMD suggested during the
Arduino 3 announcement
moving on to hunt Showdown where the
7800 XTX and RTX 4080 are neck and neck
delivering just over 250 FPS that made
amd's Flagship just 25 faster than the
RTX 390 TI and 32 faster than the 6950
XT
the 4K data is much the same as in the
700xt and RTX 4080 are on par though
this time that meant the 700 XTX was
just 14 faster than the 390 TI and 30
faster than the 6950 XT
the outer worlds uses the Unreal Engine
4 and this game engine typically favors
GeForce gpus and that's certainly the
case with this title still although the
700 XTX was 10 slower than the RTX 4080
When comparing the average frame rate
the one percent lows were higher for the
Radeon GPU and we do see a bit of that
in our testing all of that said though
at the 4K resolution the one percent
lows are more in line with the average
frame rates and hit the 700 XTX was nine
percent slower than the RTX 4080 and
just 26 faster than the 6950 XT
now as we've seen in our recent Call of
Duty Modern Warfare 2 benchmarks this
game loves Radeon gpus and this is
certainly very true we're looking at the
7900 XTX where it pumped out an
incredible 311 FPS on average at 1440p
and that made it a massive 42 faster
than the RTX 4080 and 28 faster than the
40 90. these results are certainly
outliers in our testing but Modern
Warfare 2 and Warzone 2 are very popular
games so this is great news for AMD
the 7900 XTX even managed to Edge out
the RTX 4090 at 4K with 193 FPS making
it five percent faster and then 35
faster than the 4080. moreover a 43
improvement over the 6950 XT is very
impressive though again given amd's
announcement you will probably expecting
this sort of margin to be more of the
norm if not a worse case scenario for
the new arduino3 flagship
The Hitman 3 results are heavily CPU
Limited at 1440p with these next-gen
gpus so the 700 XTX was able to match
the 4080 and 40 90. bumping up the
resolution of 4K showed some great
results for the new Arduino 3 GPU as it
was 15 faster than the RTX 48 and just
10 slower than the RTX 4090 again I
suspect these are the sort of margins
that game is anticipating the arrival of
the 700 XTX were expecting to be more of
the norm
generally Radeon gpus do perform really
well in Horizon zero Dawn but I've got
to say the 700 XTX was quite
underwhelming here trailing the RTX 4080
by a five percent margin at 1440p to
come in just 14 fast in the 6950 XT
yikes
the 4K results were a lot better but
even so we're looking at RTX 4080 light
performance meaning the 7900 XTX was
just 26 faster than the 6950 XT and 16
faster than the RTX 39 ETI
Now f122 by default does enable Ray
tracing with the ultra high preset at
least for Hardware that supports it so
this is why the 700 XTX is slower than
expected AMD is still well behind when
it comes to RT performance and we'll
look more at that shortly for now though
we can see that when playing f122 using
the highest quality preset for the 700
XTX is 11 slow in the RTX 4080 and a
mere five percent faster than the 3090
TI that said in this example it is 55
fast on the 6950 XT suggesting that rdna
3's RT support has improved from rdna 2.
then at the 4K resolution the 700 XTX
drops down to the 39 ETI with 56 FPS on
average making it 13 slower than the RTX
4080 and 36 slower than the 4090 so it
is a bit of a Wipeout here for AMD that
said thanks to the use of RT it was a
massive 65 fast on the 6950 XT so
there's at least that
cyberpunk 2077 performance at 1440p
looks quite good for the 700 XTX as here
it was five percent faster than the RTX
4080 delivering 135 FPS on average that
said when compared to previous
generation products it was just 24
faster than the 6950 XT and 26 faster
than the 3090 TI
the 7100 XTX does remain strong at the
4K resolution and in fact was able to
extend its margin over the RTX 4080 out
to 9 with 70 FPS on average that made it
27 faster than the RTX 3090 TI and 43
farther than 6950 XT which is a decent
result
I've got to say the Dying Light 2
results are a bit underwhelming though
at 1440p the 700 XTX was only able to
match the average frame rate of the RTX
4080 with much lower one percent lows it
was also just 17 faster than the 6950 XT
which is no doubt very disappointing for
those of you with a previous generation
Flagship hoping to upgrade
all that said though the 4K data was a
bit more favorable this year the 700 XTX
was five percent faster than the RTX
4080 and the one percent lows were a lot
better the result though relative to
amd's own 6950 XT was again very
disappointing as the new GPU was just 17
faster
Halo infinite is a game AMD skipped over
for their review guide opting not to
show performance and that's likely
because the 700 XTX is very weak here
AMD says they are looking into it though
so it's possible a future driver
corrects performance but for now this is
what it looks like so this once Pro AMD
title sees the 7900 xgx trailing the RTX
4080 by a rather large 16 margin making
it just 21 faster than the RTX 39 HDI
and 26 faster than the 6950 XT so very
disappointing compared to previous
generation Flagship parts
the 7900 XTX shapes up a little bit
better at the 4K resolution as here it
was six percent sold in the RTX 4080 and
a more impressive 24 faster than the
3090 TI and 35 faster than the 6950 XT
last up we have shot of the Tomb Raider
and I was quite surprised to find the
700 XTX trailing the 4080 by a 13 margin
worse still this minute was just 18
faster than the 6950 XT
the margins did improve a little at 4K
here it was six percent slower than the
4080 and 25 faster than the 6950 XT so
better but still quite poor overall
alrighty so now it is time for the 16
game average data and we'll start at
1440p here we see that on average the
700 XTX and RTX 4080 were neck and neck
with around 180 FPS on average that
means the 7900 XTX is 17 sold in the RTX
4090 which given the price is obviously
quite a good result though it's also
only 25 faster than the 3090 TI and 6950
XT it was also just 35 faster than the
RTX 3090 and 6900 XT so for those of you
with previous generation Flagship parts
that might not be worth the upgrade
now looking at the 4K data the 700 XTX
was 20 slower than the RTX 4090 but four
percent faster than the RTX 4080 so
again we're looking at 4080 light
performance and that made the 700 XTX 26
faster than the RTX 30 90gi and 35 fast
in the 6950 XT so not nearly as good as
the 50 or greater many of you are hoping
for that said it was 49 faster than AMD
6900 XT
now although we didn't go over the 1080p
data as it is largely CPU limited I've
got the averages for you so let's just
take a quick look at that again the 700
XTX and RTX 4080 are basically on par
but this time the Radeon GPU is just six
percent slower than the 4090 again
because of the CPU bolnik we also see
the 7900 XTX was just 21 faster than the
6950 XT
now let's take a look at Ray tracing
performance with and without upscaling
if you recall the 700 XTX was 13 slower
than the RTX 48 in our previous f122
testing as the game enables rtfx by
default when using the ultra high preset
here with the ultra high preset but with
the rtfx disabled the 700 XTX pumped out
260 FPS making it 13 faster than the RTX
4080 and 51 faster than the 6950 XT
now with rt plus upscaling enabled so
just FSR 1.0 for the Radeon gpus the
7900 XTX was still 10 faster than the
RTX 48 using dlss but this is hardly an
Apples to Apples comparison now at the
native 4K the 700 XTX was seen
previously to be 13 slower than the 4080
but a massive 65 faster than the 6950 XT
so there are good gains to be had over
previous generation rdna 2 gpus when
using Ray tracing
next up we have Watchdogs Legion and
this one doesn't support FSR so
upscaling is really only available for
the GeForce gpus in short using the very
high preset with rt disabled the 700 XTX
was nine percent faster than the RTX
4080 and 36 faster than the 6950 XT then
with rt set to ultra but no upscaling
the 7900 XTX was 19 slower than the RTX
4080 with just 44 FPS on average but it
was also 52 faster than the 6950 XT so
some decent gains there for Arduino 3
over arduino2 but it also meant that the
700 XTX was only up to speed with last
Generations 3090 TI when it comes to RT
performance
moving on to Marvel's Guardians of the
Galaxy we see that the 7900 XTX and RTX
4080 are neck and neck with 140 FPS
making them 27 faster than the 6950 XT
with Ray tracing enabled but no
upscaling the new rdna3 GPU rendered 53
FPS on average which is basically the
same performance received by the 6950 XT
and 27 slower than the RTX 4080. so I
have to assume this is some kind of
driver issue
next up we have Dying Light 2 and please
note the performance shown previously In
Dying Light 2 was done so using the high
preset and this uses DirectX 11. the ray
tracing preset forces DirectX 12 and
this seems to break the 7900 XTX for
example using the high preset it was
five percent faster than the RTX 4080
But Here Without RT enabled so disabling
the rtfx that would have otherwise been
enabled using this preset the 7900 XTX
was 25 slow on the RTX 4080. now with
those rtfx enabled so the standard
untouched array tracing quality preset
the 700 XTX managed just 27 FPS on
average the same performance delivered
by the 39 ATI and 50 stronger
performance than that of the 6950 XT but
it was also 31 slow on the RTX 4080 so
good gains relative to previous gen AMD
Hardware but not good when compared to
Ada Lovelace
the last guy I'm going to look at
raytracing performance with is cyberpunk
2077 and here the 700 XTX couldn't even
match the 3090 TI trailing it by a 20
margin with just 20 FPS on average and
that meant that it was 35 slower than
the RTX 4080 but it was at least 54
faster than the 6950 XT
with appscaling enabled so FSR 2.1
quality for the Radeon gpus the 700 XTX
was able to deliver 39 FPS making it 44
faster than the 6950 XT but it was still
15 slower than the 39 inchi which was of
course using dlss and then 33 slower
than the RTX 4080
now it's time for a look at total system
power consumption and here the 700 XTX
pushed total usage to 468 Watts In Dying
Light too so in terms of power usage it
is comparable to the RTX 3080 and 3090
and that means system usage was nine
percent lower than that of the 6950 XT
but 16 greater than the RTX 4080 making
the 4080 the more efficient GPU
we also see that power consumption
between the 4080 and 700 XTX was more
comparable and do maternal here the
Radeon GPU push total system uses just
four percent higher that was also only
just four percent lower than that of the
6950 XT then we have Hitman 3 and again
the 4080 and 700 XTX were very similar
basically comparable with other previous
generation high-end gpus excluding the
3090 TI of course which was quite the
power Pig
and here we see when locking the frame
rate to 90 FPS in cyberpunk 2077 that
the 700 XTX push total system power
usage 24 higher than that of the RTX
4080 again confirming that arduino3
isn't nearly as power efficient as
nvidia's Ada Lovelace architecture
okay so time for the all-important cost
per frame analysis and we'll start with
the msrps using the 4K data so if all
current and previous generation gpus
were to be sold at the MSRP the 700 XTX
would actually be the best value deal on
the market undercutting the RX 6800 XT
by a five percent margin and the 6950 XT
by a massive 32 percent more importantly
though it's almost a 20 Improvement in
terms of cost per frame when compared to
the RTX 4080. now here's a look at GPU
pricing using the current Newegg data
which will be about a week old by the
time you see this video the RTX 4080 is
currently selling for at least 1270 us
so 70 US above MSRP and for this
comparison we have to assure the 700 XTX
will be available for the advertised 1
000 us but of course that is by no means
guaranteed but let's just say that it is
that'll be a 24 discount in terms of
cost per frame when compared to the RTX
4080 and as we just saw with both at the
MSRP the Radeon GPU will be at least 20
better value in today's market it is
also slightly better value than the 6900
XT and 6950 XT so there is that while
the only products to offer a better
price to Performance ratio include the
RX 6800 and 6800 XT both of which are
significantly slower so when it comes to
rasterization Performance though f122
was tested with rt but when it comes to
largely rasterization performance the
7900 XTX is quite good in terms of value
at least relative to the terrible value
RTX 4080 hmm
before wrapping up the testing here's a
quick look at thermal and clock behavior
of the AMD reference model installed in
an ATX case in a 21 degree room the AMD
Radeon RX 7900 XTX peaked at a hot spot
temperature of 80 degrees after an hour
of gameplay with a peak average diet
temperature of 67 degrees and this was
achieved with a fan speed of 1900 RPM
we also saw a typical operating clock
frequency of 2275 megahertz and the
memory operated at 19.9 gigabits per
second so just shy of the advertised 20
gigabits per second overall the
reference card run cool and relatively
quiet so I expect all partner models to
work very well and that's something we
will look at in the near future alright
so at the start of this video I touched
on how hyped the Radeon RX 7900 XTX has
been AMD themselves are largely blamed
for this but just to make sure that I
wasn't off base I pulled our audience
asking what their expectations were
based on amd's arduino3 announcement
where they compared the 7900 XTX to the
6950 XT showing gains of between 50 to
70 percent the majority of you expected
the 700 XTX to be on average at least 50
percent faster than the 6950 XT based on
what you'd seen so far from AMD with 60
of all the people who voted voting 50 or
more it's clear AMD messed up and set
expectations way too too high at fifty
percent faster than the 6950 XT the 700
XTX would be at least 10 to 15 faster
than the RTX 4080 and really not a great
deal slower than the 4090. in reality
though the 700 XTX was on average just
35 faster than the 6950 XT placing it on
par with the RTX 4080. now look I could
give AMD 40 faster let's go with that
that's probably achievable an extra five
percent over what I showed margin of
error rounding differences uh they used
a faster CPU so that could also help
broaden the Gap a bit there but 40
really as high as I could go in our 16
game average it's certainly not going to
be higher than that when accounting for
those other variables
and amd's own review guide showed the
700 XTX to be on average 43 faster than
the 6950 XT so slightly more favorable
than our matchup though the sample of
games was different and the hardware
used again was different they used a
zen4 CPU for example
the point is though I think people are
expecting more and that's going to lead
to a lot of negative feedback from
Gamers and if that is indeed the case
AMD has no one to blame but themselves
but let's just put hype aside is the 700
XTX any good minus a few teething issues
which I'll discuss in a moment I think
this is a decent product certainly not
bad compared to the competition but also
not good either although the 7900 XTX
looks quite good in terms of value for
those interested primarily in
rasterization performance at a thousand
dollars US it's not exactly cheap sure
it looks pretty good next to the RTX
4080 delivering the same level of
performance for 200 US less but the RTX
4080 sucks at the current asking price
and that's not just me saying that it's
Gamers at large as sales across the
globe for RTX 4080 has been extremely
weak that's a problem because in almost
every measurable metric the RTX 4080 is
a superior product to that of the 7900
XTX the RTX 4080 offers comparable
rasterization performance significantly
better Ray tracing performance better
upscaling as dlss is superior to FSR it
also uses less power and the media
engine is better supported really the
only thing going for the 700 XTX is the
fact that it's 17 cheaper but I feel
like when spending a thousand dollars US
on a graphics card that's a lot of money
a thousand dollars U.S do you really
care about 200 U.S wouldn't you just
spend the extra money to get the
superior product if we're talking about
lower price tiers let's say 600 to 700
just a hundred dollars difference there
the percentage difference is actually
similar but I feel someone looking at
spending 600 might value one hundred
dollars a lot more than someone spending
a thousand dollars values two hundred
dollars it's an assumption I know but a
thousand dollars is a a lot of money
depending on a graphics card at that
point are you really looking to cut
corners on things like Ray tracing
performance upscaling and so on
all of that said I feel AMD needs to be
coming in at least 20 cheaper if not 25
cheaper so 900 us would be a more
appropriate price given what we've seen
which is kind of humorous given that I
felt the RTX 4080 really needed to be
900 for it to be an exciting product and
again given sales I feel like I was
probably right about that one
but that's the kind of discount where I
can say for most of you the benefits of
the GeForce GPU simply aren't worth the
price premium for 900 us you really
would just get the 7900 XTX
after all if you're someone who mostly
plays multiplayer games like myself
stuff like Ray tracing it's really not
that appealing you're really after raw
FPS performance and in stuff like war
zone 2 Call of Duty the 700 XTX just
delivers that in Spades but it's 17 less
than the RTX 4080 it's still not really
the obvious choice
my time with the 700 XTX wasn't Flawless
either as I ran into a few game crashes
and I spoke with other reviewers who did
suffer a few crashes as well and now
this could simply be a pre-release
driver issue that AMD will solve for
public release or it could be something
that Gamers will be plagued with for a
few months to come it's really hard to
say at this point in time I also ran
into a frustrating black screen issue
but it's not the black screen issue that
5700 XT owners may be familiar with this
one simply required me to disconnect and
then reconnect the display the game
didn't crash for some reason it would
Flicker and then go black this didn't
happen a lot it didn't happen often so
this may be something that nobody else
reports and again this could be
something that's just to do with the
pre-release driver and you won't see
this with the public release driver
again I don't know in any case this was
a rare occurrence it only happened twice
in all of my testing so hopefully again
this isn't something that end users will
experience but it is worth mentioning
given the other stability issues I ran
into with the review driver
also Jared from Jared's Tech ran into a
slow boot issue with his Intel test
system where the 700 XTX would take
twice as long to load into windows from
startup when compared to something like
an RTX 4080 or really any other GPU MSI
also confirmed this issue with Jared and
at this point the cause is unknown so I
suspect MSI would be working with AMD on
the solution and it's unclear if this
affects other motherboards but it was a
confirmed issue so I'm reporting it here
though I should note that I didn't run
into this issue with my MSI am4
Motherboard
anyway I don't want to make the Radeon
RX 7900 XTX sound like a broken product
as our testing was mostly smooth but
there were a few hiccups along the way
that I hope we can blame on the review
driver I guess we'll know soon enough
overall the Radeon RX 7900 XTX looks to
be a decent product at least relative to
its GeForce competitor but whether or
not it's worth it at a thousand dollars
US will depend on how much stock you
place in stuff like Ray tracing
performance also for those of you with
previous generation flagships the 7900
XTX simply won't be worth the upgrade
and while it is a big step forward from
something like an RX 6800 it is also
roughly twice the price so it's not
really moving the needle forward when it
comes to value and worse still the RX
6800 and 7900 XTX really could be
members of the same product family
frankly neither the 7900 XTX or RTX 4080
would have me racing out to buy one so
I guess we'll have to wait around and
see what the lower tier models have to
offer but I'm certainly not holding my
breath certainly not for anything
amazing and that is really going to do
it for this review if you did appreciate
this one then please do give it a like
it was a lot of work and you can also
subscribe for more content as I said we
have our 7900 XT review coming and
there'll probably be some partner cards
it'll be worth checking out so we'll do
that also we have float plane or patreon
if you want to support the channel and
get some really cool perks in return
you've got access to our monthly live
stream Tim and I will be doing that uh
we'll be doing that towards the end of
the month we do q and A's behind the
scenes content and we also have
exclusive Discord server for members
only so pretty cool stuff there so if
you're interested to check it out but if
not perfectly fine
and I would like to thank you for
watching this video I'm your host Steve
see you next time
[Music]